I'm a total wildlife nerd.
But I’m also a career technologist,
and it took me 20 years to figure out
how to combine the two
towards wildlife conservation.
But I think I finally got it.
Technology has come so far
in that time in generating data
about our planet and its other
non-human inhabitants.
For example, there's a satellite in space
that's dedicated to tracking
the movements of hundreds of species.
We can pluck DNA samples
from rivers, soil and dung
to identify individual animals.
And whales and seals are swimming
around right now with sensors on,
collecting ocean data for us.
Now, this data is incredibly valuable
to the science of protecting the planet.
But I think it could be
even more valuable.
What if we use that data
to give wild animals
a unique digital identity
that's recognizable by humans?
Now why would we do this?
Well, most of us have a digital identity
that we use to communicate
and socialize with each other.
But Albert in St. Louis, for example,
has no way to create a connection
with an orangutan in Borneo.
How can we expect him to empathize
with its protection?
If we want to preserve all life on Earth,
we need to create relationships
with all life on Earth.
And relationships are built upon
recognizing someone's unique identity.
So maybe giving one to that orangutan
could create a bond with Albert
that helps them both in the real world.
Now, this is not
as far-fetched as it seems.
The technology
and the data exist to do it.
But it's not enough to just
create the identities.
They need a place to come alive
and be found by humans.
Somewhere that creates
an immersive and active way
to stay engaged.
Well, if current predictions come true,
most of our socializing, work and play
will shift to games,
virtual spaces and yes, the metaverse.
And that's where stories will be told
and relationships built.
So for every human avatar
that is interacting
or consuming in these spaces,
let’s have the same
for Mweituria the elephant,
Ataia the Jaguar, Fio the orangutan
and hundreds of thousands more.
And the events of their lives,
as supported by the data,
can be recreated digitally.
That might be the health of Fio,
the migration of Mweituria,
a newborn cub to Ataia.
And these events, and others,
create the moments
for people to feel the space
to feel emotionally bonded.
Not because they all of a sudden want to,
but because they now have access
that they never did before.
Some will use that space
to connect directly
with orangutan researchers in Borneo.
Others will identify new patterns
in elephant movements.
Some will learn about deforestation
by actually witnessing it.
And we’ll monetize this
soon-to-be-trillion-dollar sector
to help finance further science
and habitat protection.
Which means that virtual worlds
can directly benefit the real world
as opposed to being detached from it.
And we've been experimenting with this
using the real data of animals
like Fio and others.
And we found that
while our vision is still many years
away from being realized,
the platforms to make it
happen already exist.
Microsoft's Flight Simulator,
it includes two trillion
of the world's trees.
It could include all the world's wildlife.
Adidas recently included five GPS-tracked
animals as athletes in its fitness app
for its users to compete against.
It could include thousands more.
And Fortnite recently held
a virtual concert ... with Travis Scott.
They transported
over 27 million of their users
to a fictional world
to witness that concert.
Let's hold the next one
in the Amazon rainforest.
Imagine if Ataia the Jaguar
walks by during the show.
Now, I'll admit I have fears
that some of what I'm advocating
could create a greater divide
between people and the natural world.
If I could, I'd just pick everybody up,
I’d plop them in Borneo, and I’d have them
spend an hour with Fio instead.
But Fio's natural world is literally
dying in front of our eyes.
We need a seismic shift in how we create
relationships with other species.
Otherwise, yeah, the next 100 years
of wildlife conservation
will continue to be
an uphill, losing battle.
It's only a matter of time
before some version of the metaverse
changes the way we spend our time
and engage with each other.
And however you may feel about that,
we have to make sure
that Mweituria, Ataia, Fio
and millions more animals are included,
play a role and benefit.
And not get left behind.
Thank you.
(Applause)